good afternoon everybody and welcome
back for the second of professor Wendy
Browns Tanner lectures politics and
knowledge and nihilistic times thinking
with Max Weber we were treated yesterday
to a fabulous beginning to this series
of events we'll reconvene tomorrow at
10:30 for its conclusion a roundtable
discussion with Professor Brown and Yale
professors Katie Lofton and Paul north
now I am NOT so misguided as to attempt
a summary of the nuanced and rich
ruminations that Professor Brown led us
through yesterday neither am i so
presumptuous as to suggest what
questions she will or should address
this afternoon so these brief scattered
remarks to introduce her today will
serve in effect as tokens of my thanks
to her for the thoughts she has set in
motion and of my absolute conviction
that she would do much more of the same
today the two talks from the end of max
weber career that Professor Brown has
concerned herself with are usually
translated under the titles politics as
a vocation and science as a vocation
she has already signaled a first problem
with these translations the rendering of
dissing shaft as science instead of the
broader knowledge the German originals
are politique Alba roof and visit shaft
Osby roof the roof from roofin to call
vocation from local walk RA to call yet
the word vocation in today's English has
distanced itself from that vocalization
that calling from somewhere vocation has
taken on pragmatic suggestions of
employment occupation trade craft and so
forth to title favours talks politics as
a calling and knowledge as a calling
points us instead towards some of the
issues and conundrums professor Brown
has already so productively raised a
calling would seem to be a trajectory
utterly opposed to nihilism a calling
would seem to be allied with a
seriousness of intent a weightiness a
sobriety which professor Brown opposed
yesterday to Nietzsche's gay science as
a stance for countering nihilism a
calling would clearly still today
toward a religious experience of some
kind such as a vocation and calling both
used to connote and a calling above all
would draw us toward that famous Weber
and phenomenon of charisma which he took
over from writings of his sign that
associated it clearly with religious
experience and with the mysterious power
granted therein a vocation does not
quite have the power to rally itself
toward these alliances the way a calling
does in having this effect however a
calling accentuates the cross circuits
and short circuits in our thought that
Professor Brown has already begun to
highlight charisma after all has been
for most of us a suspect category a
lodging for nihilism since long before
the world according to Trump some of us
look back guiltily I think that how the
category itself seemed to us to have
taken on a new innocent and happy life
at the election of Barack Obama and a
calling brings to mind Alta Sarah's
interpolation usually glossed as a
hailing by which ideological and
repressive State apparatuses operate as
modes of naturalized subject formation
these apparatuses are the ideological
analogue of a to the monopoly of the
legitimate use of political force that
served for Weber as his very definition
of a state at the same time they set in
motion the machinery of instrumental
rationality against which he railed the
question of charisma as calling comes
then to be untangled with false
consciousness as hailing where are we to
seek in this tangle legitimate modes of
authority what is their force or why
have what we so often thought of as
forms of authoritative knowledge cease
to have any appreciable force hard
science itself for example having little
or no influence over the neoliberal
greed of fossil fuel industries or all
of us the public that burn their
products professor Browne yesterday
raised the toast or in question what
then what must we do perhaps in the end
I will be presumptuous after all and in
petitioning her to raise one more word
steeped in religious history and
experience what then professor Browne
must we students intellectual
and academics do when the ideological
apparatus have come to be directed by a
prophecy of information in social media
over which all controls as to truth
content are and strangled in the coils
of Technology when we are faced with our
excommunication from the society in
which we work launched into
specializations that seem to widen this
X communicative gap and all to liable to
enact what you have called unknowing
grimace nihilism signature please join
me in welcoming to the podium professor
Wendy Brown
[Applause]
thank you
I have a little glaring alright there we
are thank you I'm gonna put this away
these are the first things to go in our
new ecological age it's always nice to
offer them it's better to carry your own
Gary thank you the conversationalist in
me is very tempted to toss this and
simply respond but that's not what I was
paid for so tomorrow we'll do that
yesterday as Gary just said we pondered
Faber's efforts to counter nihilism at
the sight of politics especially through
political action animated by responsible
selfless pursuit of a collective cause
today I'm going to turn to vapours
efforts in science as a vocation to
overcome nihilistic effects in knowledge
and the Academy a project that for him
depends on the severe depoliticization
of both knowledge and the academy and a
project that I think ultimately fails
fails in his own terms and fails us both
the effort and the failure however are
useful to our own thinking about
responsible post nihilist knowledge
politics and post nihilist world making
so this afternoon what I'm going to do
is examine at some length first Faber's
account of nihilism and knowledge before
trying to think with and against that
account for our own time one preparatory
note one that Gary has partially taken
care of
misson shaft routinely translated as
science refers to all system
academic study not just the natural or
the hard sciences but there's more at
the core of the Humboldt e'en model of
education that formed Weber and to which
he was dedicated in his time the term
visit shaft also carried implications of
knowledge pursuit that was both unbiased
and independent of influence especially
by church state and market knowledge
that was therefore capable of arriving
at truth
it's this complex meaning bundle that is
at stake each time we hear science in
vapers lecture weber opened science as a
vocation with a dark view of
contemporary german academic life
there's it's futile organization poor
conditions for advancement frequent
failure to reward excellence there are
the confines of specialization and what
he underscores as the absolutely
inevitable eclipse of every achievement
by scientific progress above all there
is Sciences own disenchanting effect
with its promise that we can in
principle understand everything science
Weber insists depletes whatever it
touches of mystery and intrinsic value
it believes spirit with explanation in
its way than science knowledge vision
shaft is as violent as politics and as
desacralized as capitalism in its way it
violates and desacralized is not
people's nation's vocations and
relations but meaning and value
themselves it topples faith and puts
nothing in its place it dispirit saz it
rationalizes whatever it touches it
divorces progress from the millenarian
promise of improvement emancipation or
happiness and reduces it instead simply
to accumulation of knowledge and
technique it leaves the world more
suffuse dwith power but more empty of
meaning when it finds it such is the
deep nihilism that Weber believes we
face consequent to the dethronement of
religion
authority and the mystery of nature with
knowledge as science topples religious
and theological perspectives on origins
order and meaning it cannot replace what
it has destroyed the inclination to do
so more than merely misguided is for
Weber itself a dangerous nihilistic
effect the voids open in a radically
desacralized world created demand he
says for profits and demagogues
everywhere at the same time performances
in the realm of knowledge that properly
belong in the church and public life are
themselves part of nihilism destructive
force in which as Weber formulates that
quote the ultimate and most sublime
values have withdrawn from public life
from another angle in science as a
vocation and the essays on method from
which Weber draws much of the argument
Weber is at war he's at war with Marx
and Nietzsche for the soul of the social
sciences contesting what he regards as
the norm Laden foe science of Marx and
the anti science of Nietzsche he's at
war with academic colleagues who preach
in the classroom whether German
nationalism value positivism or
syndicalism the Nationalists make the
university quote into a Theological
Seminary except that it lacks the
latter's religious dignity the
positivist he says make a category error
they refuse the contem dictum to submit
everything to critical scrutiny issuing
the interpretative dimension of
understanding action and values and
dangerously over esteem the coordinates
and the norms of the present the
syndicalists both spurn objectivity and
exploit the power of the podium the
academic podium in what he insists is
the inegalitarian setting of a classroom
weber is also at war with those who
believe that truth rests in balancing or
achieving compromise between contesting
worldviews that he says is a technique
of politics not science and it expresses
nihilistic relativism and trivialization
of facts and ultimate worldviews
he's at war with those who would submit
diverse views to competition a technique
he calls a market one not science and
expressing the invasion of the
University by market values he's at war
with those who pretend quote the facts
speak for themselves
when facts do not speak at all when this
likely means that both matters of
interpretation and what he insists on
calling inconvenient facts have been
strategically ignored moves that bring
the rhetorical slights of hand
appropriate to parliamentary debate into
the classroom he's at war with those who
believe they achieved neutrality by
structuring their historical or
sociological accounts with realpolitik
with Darwinian adaptation or with
meta-narratives of progress each is an
ungrounded theological remainder he's at
war with economists who believe their
science establishes the normative
supremacy of capitalism when all it does
is describe its mechanism he's at war
with philosophers and social theorists
who believe they can assess let alone
certify the validity of norms rather
than merely analyze their predicates
logics entailments and implications and
he is at war with those who believe in
transcendental Reason who acknowledge
neither hermeneutics nor differing modes
of rationality within which there will
always be irrationalities Weber is at
war but his enemies are not timeless
stalwarts rather he takes much of what
he is fighting to symptom Atty the
political epistemological and
existential crises of his time he
understands his moral political age to
be won simultaneously drained of value
proliferating value and cheapening value
his age is one in which value judgments
themselves are reduced to what he calls
judgments of taste one that fosters
personality in place of integrity and
honesty one that fosters license within
unprecedented orders of domination it's
an age he famously depicts in the
Protestant ethic and spirit of
capitalism as
featuring sensuous without heart
specialists without spirit where neither
feeling nor intellect are preserved from
rationalization a rationalization that
simultaneously renders us cogs and
economic machineries and superficial
individualís truth has come apart from
meaning and value it resides only in
facts themselves infinite in number a
reality he says that is so hard to bear
that it generates reaction in the form
of polemics positivism and
millenarianism progress no longer
comprises growing happiness peace or
truth it's limited to advancements and
knowledge themselves paradoxical as they
provide the basis for growing
organizational technological economic
and political powers that escape human
control and become world blistering
forces of power without right boundary
breakdown is also a key symptom of the
age nothing stays in its place because
absent a moral lodestar as well as
traditional organizing principles place
itself loses its coordinates and its
value in the domain of knowledge the
ramifications of this exceed the problem
of impurity or Boulder is a ssin rather
the incessant mixing of what Weber
refers to repeatedly as quote absolutely
heterogeneous practices most notably the
analysis of facts and value judgments
about them that mixing of those
practices degrades both thus
intensifying cynicism and disregard for
facts truth accountability and values in
short nihilism ramifies as it corrodes
the boundaries between preaching and
teaching entertainment and information
culture and politics as depth sobriety
historical consciousness and care for
both the soul and the world give way to
superficiality excitability
ratification present ISM Weber responds
to this crisis and the spiraling
miscegenation of elements at foments
with his infamous stipulation of arch
opposites and an epistemological and
ontological hygiene aimed at isolating
these opposites from each other
the familiar cases are politics versus
knowledge the classroom versus the
public square fact value empirical and
theoretical claims normative judgments
and the truth of empirical propositions
for Weber though not mere conceptual
tidiness but the world itself is at
stake in drawing and enforcing these
opposition's if the relative Organa sysm
of earlier epochs has given way to
fragmentation and specialization in the
Age of capitalism bureaucracy and
secularism this means order once
maintained by hierarchy and authority
has been replaced by what he terms the
inanimate machineries capitalism
bureaucracy and so forth that are also
cleaved by the disorder of value
concatenation proliferation with both
Organa sysm and Authority thus receding
tightly enforced organization alone
keeps things in place and that is why
notwithstanding Weber sensitivity to
what he calls the chaos of infinitely
differentiated and contradictory
complexes of ideas and feelings in any
epic or ideational regime and
notwithstanding his admonition to
scholars to avoid conflating concepts
and topologies with reality favors way
through nihilism in the intellectual
sphere depends upon epistemological
ontological distinctions that more than
descriptive are sent into the field as
police but why formulate these
absolutely heterogeneous spirit spheres
of endeavor and practice knowledge
politics facts values not simply as diff
but as opposites that destroy each other
if they touch or mix favors adamancy on
this front aims to quarantine nihilistic
effects ranging from the final
destruction of truth that destruction
prevails everywhere for him except in
empirical knowledge to the final
destruction of meaning which prevails
everywhere except in value asserted
values the kind we talked about
yesterday to the final destruction of
greatness which prevails everywhere
except Bayreuth calling dedication to a
cause larger than oneself for which one
sacrifices the self
thus for example for him only by
insulating the certainty of facticity
from the absolute undecidability of
values can the nihilistic condition that
assaults and degrades both be repelled
only by insulating knowledge from
charisma can the classroom as he puts it
unlocked the world by means of the
intellect
when students crave meaning in a world
of moral chaos and paradoxically only by
imposing unbridgeable moats between
church politics and knowledge can the
elements they once harbored together be
secured in the wake of their
fragmentation Faber's protocols then do
not simply shed the fetters of a less
scientific era for the contemporary one
rather they address the world destroying
D sublimation and boundary breakdowns of
nihilism with a program of hygiene they
aim at challenging values warriors and
politicians of every stripe who would
Bend facticity to their cause to the
point of breaking it they aim to
challenge journalists and teachers who
practice open partisanship via foe
objectivity selecting and arranging
facts said to speak for themselves they
challenge the conceit that neutrality is
obtained by balancing or synthesizing
views through competition among ideas or
through finding middle ground
they seek to preserve truth by confining
it to facts and to preserve value by
confining it to politics where its
undecidability is on permanent display
since favors more conventionally
understood as simply codifying protocols
of a value neutral social science for a
secular age I want to pause a little bit
over the specific crisis for knowledge
that vapors aiming to redress with his
category purifications and separations
what's vanished in recent decades he
writes in a 1917 essay the meaning of
ethical neutrality is and I'm quoting
him the widespread conviction among
social science scholars that of the
various possible points of view in the
domain of practical political
preferences ultimately only one was the
correct one end quote
in instead he continues quote a
patchwork of cultural values and
personalities to advance those values
have replaced the relatively impersonal
because Supra personal character of the
old ethical imperative end quote
in addition to value proliferation
truths dethronement in morals and
politics elevates the individual and
personality as carriers of value this in
turn creates the demand for demagoguery
in all spheres
however the fusion of values with
personality for him is especially
troubling in the domain of knowledge and
its transmission as facticity wobbles
along with ethical monoculture the
politico and the preacher invade the
classroom dressed in professorial garb
thus the very historical conditions
necessitating pristine scholarly
integrity respect for facts
consideration of values only as analytic
objects undermine it with the rise of
personality that cult of personality
Weber suggests is everywhere students
crave it teachers rise to it and
and today of course the ubiquitous
culture of celebrity combined with
metrics for student evaluation of
pedagogy positively demands a-- the
classroom weber insists is for training
not molding students the distinction
matters it's for developing capacities
not shaping views this means teaching
the importance of what he calls
inconvenient facts distinguishing facts
from evaluations and judgments and
disciplining students to quote repress
the impulse to exhibit their own
personal tastes or sentiments in their
studies they must be taught instead he
argues that intellectual greatness rests
in training hard work selfless devotion
and restraint all the familiar
protestant virtues bundled into the
scholarly vocation these demands aim not
merely to harness but choke the will to
power in intellectual life though as
Nietzsche and Freud understood that life
force would have to go somewhere and
we'll need to keep our eye on that as we
go along tonight weber also knows that
these demands aggrandized the aesthetic
forces objectivism neutrality dispassion
denial of the very subject of knowing
that nietzsche understood as turning us
relentlessly against ourselves our
senses bodies historicity faculties of
interpretation desires and will to truth
this turning nietzsche insisted would
reach a crescendo in crescendo in
Western civilization where we would come
to will nothingness even as we broke
into decadence to manifest features of
culture today
what is refusal to stem climate change
and submit human governing to market
forces other than the will to
nothingness and what is the festive
spurning of facts and truth by power
without right
other than decadence and yet
notwithstanding Nietzsche's insistence
that science dwells exclusively in facts
his fiercest and finest moments in
science as a vocation pertained to
how scholars and teachers ought to deal
with values why yesterday I argued that
weber identifies values with politics
politics with partisanship power force
and at the extreme violence in fact this
chain of identifications is a shorthand
for a historical process that weber
charts that has significant bearing on
our problem in one of his earlier
methodological essays weber identifies
values not with politics but with
culture to be cultural creatures he says
is to be and I'm quoting him endowed
with the capacity and will to take a
deliberate attitude toward the world and
lend it significance he adds that the
very concept of culture is a value
concept empirical reality becomes
culture to us because and insofar as we
relate it to value ideas and growth so
how then does value shift from the
cultural to the political plane in late
modernity values become political and
vapors term terms when they rd resonated
detached from a shared authoritative
worldview when they become matters of
struggle undecidable accept
provisionally by rhetorical legal or
physical force as we saw yesterday this
is also when they become at risk for
nihilistic hyper politicization moreover
the politicization of culture arising
from value uprooted from foundations
detached from authority is part of what
makes liberalism crack multiculturalism
in the broadest sense not just our
modern sense only works when culture
remains deep politicized a deep
politicization itself possible only so
long as a value is both anchored in
common identity politics did not change
all of that but is rather an expression
of its loss the chain of distinctly
contemporary identifications that weber
establishes between values politics
partisanship and force to
three consequential things first it
converts all values into practical
positions available to beady-eyed
analysis and situates their worldly
enactment in a realm where the distinct
disjunction between motives and effects
demands responsibility to this
disjunction rather than to principles
alone what we talked about yesterday as
the tragedy of action the separation
between principles and how they're
enacted in a dynamic world no religious
or other moral garb can shield them from
this the second thing that chain of
identifications between values politics
partisanship and force does is make the
political domain a gladiatorial theater
for context of value or what paper calls
warring godheads third it renders that
theater a potential though not
inevitable Stage four a post nihilist
recuperation and pursuit of value in the
context of historically specific forces
both raging and quiet that are
destructive of value but this chain of
identifications also has implications
for scholarship for curriculums and
pedagogy it's this chain of
identifications that animates Faber's
argument that developing and
disseminating teaching knowledge must
not be infected or inflected with values
if values are political because
inherently contingent and partisan then
the slightest normative impulse is
poison in scholarly waters more than
bias or interest it brings
undecidability but also force and
potentially charisma into a place that
is wrecked by them
again these Stern demands for
objectivity and research and analysis
for value neutrality in the classroom
are themselves the result of favours
post foundational framing of values no
universal norms or transcendental moral
commitments for him no tests or tissues
of justifications to establish validity
it's because they're ungrounded cannot
be secured by or as truth because
they're irreconcilable with each other
and because this is the nature of
politics that values at war with each
other is the essence of the political
realm far from lamenting or seeking to
solve the consequent irrationality of
the political domain weber dreams only
of tethering it to responsibilities
limiting its violence and keeping it
away from knowledge values are political
politics as a field of power and
violence knowledge materializes only
where all of this power passion
partisanship violence are in abeyance
Weber identifies this opposition in
language itself he writes in a famous
passage in science as a vocation in the
political sphere the words you use are
not the tools of academic analysis but a
way of winning others over to your
political point of view they're not
plows or plow shares to loosen the solid
soil of contemplative thought but swords
used against your opponent's weapons in
short in a lecture room it would be an
outrage to make use of language in this
way end quote
words of seduction versus words of
analysis words as weapons versus words
as plowshares war and peace the
differences are polar not matters of
degree Faber
adds whenever an academic introduces his
own value judgment a complete
understanding of the facts comes to an
end
unquote impartiality neutrality
adherence to facts and methods all of
this are absolute opposites to the
investment demeanor and effect of the
profit and the demagogue the first
traffic's in cool reason the second in
hot passion
the first seeks truth the other power
one stirs curiosity and contemplation
the other attraction or repulsion
Beiber's fierce insistence here is
precisely that eruption of the will to
power and knowledge that we knew was not
completely containable
yet Weber does not simply eject values
from the objective knowledge field this
would leave their power intact that
power has to be devitalized to insulate
knowledge from it completely so he
shifts values from the subject to the
analytic object of knowledge transposing
the register of values from the knower
to the knowable gives science dominion
over them and reveals their inner logics
and external implications as it reveals
their foundation lessness the magical
powers of values are neutralized if not
neutered by analyzing them as norms with
programmatic and policy entailments
their meaning he says is reduced in the
classroom to their relation to other
values as he puts it the obligation of
the scholar or teacher is to show you
that quote if you choose this particular
standpoint you'll be serving this
particular God and will give offense to
every other God this is how he adds we
can compel a person or at least help him
render an account of the ultimate
meaning of his own actions and if a
teacher succeeds in this respect I'd be
tempted to say he's acting in the
service of ethical forces that is the
duty to foster clarity and a sense of
responsibility end quote
now if the idea of such value neutrality
is widely challenged today
this is not what mainly interests us in
vapers wrestle to protect knowledge and
value in a nihilistic age rather what's
striking is how values are transformed
by casting them as normative positions
with analyzable precepts and logical
entailment s-- by bracketing what weber
knows well is their erotic religious and
other non rational dimensions by lifting
them from historical context that give
them specific meaning weber is the
master theorist of our attachment to
values for all sorts of historical
visceral experience ultimately ineffable
reasons he knows well that values
themselves
emanate from cultural and political
traditions of course but also from
desires ambitions hopes delusions
resentments rancor revenge everything
needs had depicted as quote erecting
ideals on earth yet vapors demand that
the scholar and especially the teacher
approached the study of value as purely
contingent standpoints with inevitable
entailments opposition's and exclusions
both distorts and d vitalizes the
practice that he identifies with our
deepest humanity it accelerates
disenchantment as it converts not merely
how things work but world views
themselves into dry logical norms
drained of their captivating and
motivating forces and their capacity to
alter the very meaning of history and
the present hence their own meaning in
practice weber insists that the academy
be this drying shed and that the factor
faculty be laborers within it this is a
more profound assault on values than
even Nietzsche's demand for their
revaluation the latter leaves intact
their seductive powers and weaponry
Faber's mandate aims at disarming them
of both and in direct contrast with
Nietzsche's reom betting of post
nihilist value in eros rather than
analytic deduction or decision Weber
treats value at this point in the
lecture as if it could be based on
rational consideration of its abstract
entailments even as he knows this is not
how values work in the world
thus do favors knowledge protocols
simultaneously abet the emptying of the
world of value and constrain the reach
of human knowing treating values thus
also requires Weber to refuse
Nietzsche's insistence on the absurdity
of accounts from nowhere
Nietzsche's eulogy for that dangerous
old conceptual fiction of a pure will
this timeless knowing subject with its I
turned in no particular direction it's
attempted expunging the active and
interpreting forces
more than merely rejecting Nietzsche's
radical interpretivism his expose of the
will to power at work in all-knowing
weber demands the asceticism that
nietzsche diagnoses as the illness
itself culminating and nihilism weber
affirms what nietzsche calls the
castration of the intellect the no to
life and also the protective instinct of
a degenerating life that nietzsche
identifies with the aesthetic ideal its
program of starving the body and the
desires as the will to power turns
against the life instincts themselves in
thinkers an ascetic life is a
self-contradiction nature rights here
rules of race Ultimo without equal that
of an insatiable power will that wants
to become master not over something in
life but over life itself over it's most
profound powerful and basic conditions
Weber knowingly insists on this
masochistic diversion of the will to
power and salts the wound by
underscoring the fleeting quality of
scientific achievement the scholar he
represents is a spiritless vessel of a
meaningless cause requiring self
negation and draining meaning from the
world one analyzes this is the ascetic
practice Nietzsche predicted would
culminate in willed nothingness it gets
worse
more than merely prescribing a regime of
spiritual intellectual starvation Faber
builds something of a torture chamber
for the man with the vocation for
science he is condemned to the frenzied
accumulation of facts combined with the
destruction of value that's at the heart
of a burrs own diagnosis of modernity
slide into darkness Sheldon Wolin rights
like the Calvinists of the protestant
ethic
weber scientific man accumulates even as
what he amasses has no more lasting
value than other things of the world
thus does weber repeat in a scholarly
register both the morphology of CAP
once it's spirit settles into what he
calls mechanical foundations and the
morphology of depression that nihilism
induces driven but aimless agitated
obsessive but without purpose desire
raging but choked repose unavailable
with eyes wide open about the modern
machineries killing human freedom value
and satisfaction Weber builds his cage
of knowledge knowledge and scholarship
from their blueprint means separated
from ends the scientist reduced to a
means the ends receding altogether a
wheel whose turns we never get off in
contrast to his crafting of the roof for
politics
Weber makes the true scholar eminent to
and replicative of these forces
embodying the frenzied accumulation and
overtaking of ends with means to become
a Slayer of value and complicit with
modern apparatuses of domination
affirming knowledge as contributing to
such power while denying completely its
enlightenment linked to human
emancipation Weber would have been
unsurprised I think by an information
age producing unrivaled capacities for
surveillance and manipulation of human
subjects an epoch of capital subjecting
everything and everyone to the
vicissitudes of Finance and academic
knowledge so compartmentalized so
sub-specialized
that most disciplines were useless in
anticipating or apprehending the
mounting crises of ecology humanity and
democracy now upon us
Weber saw the dark ahead but his path to
containing nihilistic destructions of
knowledge and truth drove straight into
it against conventional readings of a
burrs lecture on science as affirming
scientific protocols for their own sake
I've been emphasizing his nearly
hyperbolic efforts to protect knowledge
against its own
modern effects I've also been suggesting
that his approach to nihilism boundary
breakdowns its trivialization of fact
and value its evisceration of depth and
integrity its dethronement of truth that
Babers responds to this was a kind of
pharmacon in both senses of the word
escape goading to produce order and a
cure drawn from the poison his
performative counter to nihilism 'he's
ablative force was to stipulate separate
narrow and quarantine knowledge gets
rationality and secularism politics gets
charisma and its religious spirit
knowledge gets mind politics gets body
and soul knowledge is drained of passion
judgment or order for a different world
politics runs on their fuel knowledge
pursues truth politics
traffic's and power knowledge is
specialized and removed from the world
politics deals with the whole and the
visceral intended to restore order and
place when nihilistic decadence was
destroying both these divisions I've
been arguing let the beast in by another
door as Weber submitted what remained of
value to the grinding gears of
disenchantment in the knowledge realm he
surrendered its prospects for renewal to
the magical force of charismatic
domination leadership in the political
one he affirmed empirical study of the
past and present while rejecting
knowledge as critique or utopia indeed
knowledge as he conceived it was pinned
to the powers of the present only
charisma in the political realm could
break open the new and the different to
the extent that neova Berrien ism has
shaped the modus operandi of social
science in the last century I'm
suggesting that it choked and scolded
scholarly endeavor that would challenge
and replace the trajectories that have
brought us here instead disruptions have
been left largely to the acquisitive
drives of markets and technology and to
leaders and movements too often devoid
of the characteristics weber assigned
the charismatic genre restraint
selflessness responsibility a public
vision these divisions also deprived
social science of intellectual mediums
through which to fathom modern political
subjects constituted by complex desires
frustrations wounds reactions fears
anxieties indeed subjects animated often
by objection rejection subjection and
resentment as much or more than by
reflections on norms or interest at the
same time these divides abandon an
informed active democracy as either an
academic mission or an agent of
political change instead they leave that
citizenry to its cultural psychic stew
of susceptibility and exploitability in
this too weber limits the relevance of
academic endeavor to post nihilist world
making to reinforce with ardor harnessed
by knowledge or accountability instead
his protocols for knowledge meant that
the Academy would perversely withdraw
from the world at the moment but it was
released from the church opposing fact
in value as Weber does also ignores how
values acquire meanings and valence --is
through the historically specific
rationalities that administer them
specific discourses they intersect
purposes and projects that transform
them as they are actualized far from
self-governing the meaning of values in
politics is always modified by such
encounters and that's why of course
genealogies matter it's why norms in the
political sphere do not operate as
logical premises and entailments as they
do in philosophy it's why normative
political theory of the analytic variety
is in this way oxymoronic it's white
originalism on both the right and the
left is always only another political
tactic it's why complaining about the
co-optation of one's principles always
misses the point consider conceptually
liberalism
promises to protect human dignity and
political equality in fact it sacrifices
these as it intersects with powers of
class racial and gender super ordination
and is more recently transmogrified by
the governing forum of rationality we
call neoliberalism liberalism has no
pure operation outside the philosophers
study any more than socialism does thus
its poorest account of Liberty has not
merely been cynically weaponized by the
right to wave free speech banners over
Klan rallies or by corporations to
dominate electoral democracy with their
economic might or by organized
evangelicals to erode sexual and gender
equality yes these are calculated
strategic moves but they're not outside
liberalism bounds rather they nest
comfortably within and draw succour from
liberalism's neoliberal
transmogrification which supplants
democratic legislation with traditional
morality and markets to order social
life just as we cannot think well about
free speech today in abstraction from
powers of contemporary social media or
mobilize social hatred we will not think
well about liberalism in abstraction
from its plutocratic neoliberal
authoritarian and other anti-democratic
formations now this example reminds us
that a post nihilist approach to values
in both knowledge and politics requires
more than reckoning with their lack of
foundations or the disconnect between
their aims and effects and more even
than their effective charge rather a
post nihilist approach to values
requires grasping always their
embeddedness in specific forms of
governing reason and their deployment
through particular technologies and
interpretations
it requires addressing their
actualization by and amidst meanings and
powers not part of their own vocabulary
or aim if this was an element of what
Weber sought to capture with his ethic
of responsibility and political life
we would do well to incorporate it in
political and social theory as well but
no baby out with the bathwater weber is
surely right that we must teach students
about facts and facticity even as this
means teaching them as well about the
constitution and interpretation of facts
they're inescapable historical material
discursive and her hermeneutic
dimensions he's right to insist that
were bound to explain why no value
system is ever true with a capital T but
that far from bringing analysis and
judgment to an end that very condition
is what heightens the importance of
analysis and judgment he's right to
insist on self-consciousness and
restraint in preferring our own
political views even if this can't be
fulfilled in the way he demanded because
from the study of Kant to evolution to
climate change to the Constitution there
are only ever interpretations renderings
through specific languages of disclosure
and judgment
moreover however vital it is to open out
the silos and methodological lockdowns
of the current organizations protocols
and especially specializations of
knowledge it's equally vital to
articulate and protect the interval
between politics and the academy
discovery critique and reflection are
fundamentally different from political
action legislation and dicta they beckon
different subjects and subjectivity x'
draw on different languages
temporalities aims and etho thus the
demand that a curriculum comport with
any political program must always be
countered with an account of how they
destroy each other when conflated in
addition to keeping political agendas at
a distance scholarship today of course
needs protection from being bought or
invested in by the powerful valued only
for its commercial applications or job
training and from destruction by those
with anti-democratic
missions to keep the masses stupid and
manipulable even with the world in an
emergency state then where every
scholarly hand is needed on deck
we need a version of the moat between
knowledge and politics that Weber sought
to establish that mode is vital to
protecting reflection imagination and
accountability in knowledge production
and dissemination it distinguishes the
place where values are struggled for and
where they're probed and queried or as
Stewart Hall shaded the matter it
distinguishes the theoretical domain
where we deconstruct meaning make
meaning slide from the political domain
where we seek to arrest that slide in
order to make our meaning hegemonic
healthcare is a human right trees have
standing no person is illegal restore
the rule of law sciences real black
lives matter such claims cannot be taken
apart in the midst of political battle
but must be opened and queried in the
classroom critiques of racial and gender
essentialism consent autonomy choice
human rights examinations of the
slippery semiotics of corporations and
personhood or the problematic elements
of contemporary quest for sovereignty
and statehood the failures and aporia's
of constitutional democracy all these
may inform political projects but they
can't be taken on board in the midst of
an immediate political fight nothing is
more corrosive to thinking and knowledge
than domination by a political program
and nothing is more impotent in politics
than the unending reflexivity critique
and self correction required for serious
intellectual inquiry yet the relations
are as important as the corridors of
separation
especially for democratic life which
cannot survive an uneducated public in
contemporary times put the other way
around neither political life nor
education can be democratized alone and
anti-democratic forces shaping both are
mutually reinforcing as well
forming today a downward spiral indeed
erosion of access an erosion of quality
in public higher education and
denigration of the value of higher
education apart from job training are
among the most underappreciated
strategies of the combined neoliberal
and right-wing assault on democracy in
the past four decades at the same time
the combination of academic
specialization and professionalization
the steady replacement of public with
private research support and neoliberal
pressures for economic deliverables from
research and teaching together these
have diverted a great deal of university
research and teaching from public
worldly purposes exactly when we need
the opposite turn in this regard it
seems to me we have lately been too much
absorbed by issues of academic freedom
and too little by matters of academic
responsibility
the former is not trivial but it's the
latter that holds our collective future
in the context of the multiple perils I
sketched at the beginning of yesterday's
lecture it seems to me the most urgent
question for scholars today is not what
have I the right to say or do inside or
outside the classroom but rather what
curriculums strategies and classroom
conversations might contribute to
holding back the dark and looming new
possibilities what research agendas that
might not yield the same degree of
recognition or the same degree of status
as those in the mainstream might make
that contribution as well how do we
interrupt the reactive personal politics
in which students have been steeped to
incite deliberation about values
embedded in and potentially altering
large-scale economic political and
ecological trajectories how do we break
the silo ization and professionalization
of knowledge turning us away from the
world and how do students faculty and
administration alike shed absorption
with enhancing personal and
institutional capital that prevents that
break essential to this work I think is
turning hard toward rather than away
from the values from values in the
classroom and by this I don't mean
promulgating values rather as Weber
suggested classrooms are where values
may be studied as more than opinions
ideologies family party or religious
loyalties but also as more than
distractions from the empirical
technical instrumental or practical it's
where they can be deepened as world
views and considered in the context of
the specific powers that mobilize and
transmogrify them it's where they can be
examined genealogically culturally
economically and psychically that is as
complex reaction formations not only
analytically or through the prism of
morality and religion
it's where values can be discovered in
powers that disavow or consecrate them
through feigned neutrality or
technocracy and above all it's where
they can be framed as at once
undecidable yet decisive in responding
to the multiple crises of our time this
would constitute a vital counter to a
nihilistic age in which values are
trivial and instrumentalized a political
age in which they're widely perceived as
monopolized by religionists on the right
and by identity and moral dicta on the
left a counter to an era of consumer
capitalism in which they're reduced to
branding celebrity and market share a
counter to a technocratic era in which
they're buried in platforms and apps or
consigned to ethics consultants and a
counter to a secular age in which they
are presumed to be private or personal
recenter in the study of values in
higher education would also counter the
steady pressure on universities
especially public ones to elevate
vocational training and STEM fields
above all else again
that push which threatens to contract if
not eliminate the most important
remaining venue for deep study and
informed reflection on the
in ones place in it could not come at a
worse time in history if they were
worried about classroom polemics
destroying conditions for objective
learning it seems to me that is hardly
the most serious threat to classroom
integrity today nor despite the hamate
of it by the write and the media is
concerned with triggering that
widespread or important especially
outside the tiny universe of elite
schools rather it seems to me the
quotidian depressant of intellectual
seriousness among students today is
anxiety about individual futures
manifest as preoccupation with grading
rubrics and techniques for meeting
requirements with minimal investment and
then there are the crushing effects of
the unprecedented least schismatic
consciousness borne by sentient young
people today on the one hand they've
internalized the mandate to precisely
calculate and titrate their every
educational social Civic and personal
self investment relentlessly tending
their human capital value to build their
future individual prospects on the other
hand they're alert to the looming global
ecological political and economic
catastrophes that make the world in
which they're tending this value quite
likely to crash out of the universe no
generation has ever stared so directly
into its own lack of collective future
while managing such intense complex
requirements for building its personal
one more than cruel optimism this
predicament is simply too much for most
young spirits leading them either to
drop out and join extinction rebellion
or to put one entrepreneurial foot in
front of the other as if they were not
walking through and toward catastrophe
if they dwell mostly in one side of this
impossible split the other part
periodically shrieks through and a great
deal of medication may be required to
manage the suppression they are in a
mode of pre-apocalyptic survivalism as
we all are in some ways our task is to
address this condition
not by telling students what to think
but by acknowledging this predicament
and breaking it open with deliberately
post nihilist questions what are you
living for what world do you want to
live in how should or could humans order
our common arrangements and our
relationship with the nonhuman world at
this juncture in world history again
empirical analysis how things work and
material analyses what historical forces
brought us to this path what powers
organized it in the present all of these
are critical and framing and answering
such questions
literary theoretical philosophical
artistic and other modes of depicting
and interpreting the world are
indispensable as well all are part of
educating for democracy and addressing a
post nihilist development of values to
be clear this is not an argument to
place the question what is to be done at
the heart of the college curriculum nor
is it an argument for tolerating all
viewpoints in the classroom a liberal
Shibboleth that diminishes rather than
builds the stature of values weber would
have us replace that tolerance with
fearless scrutiny and hence
depersonalization of values today this
would include among other things showing
students why relentlessly personalized
justice claims I'm offended wounded
excluded and values imagined as very
nearly written on the body themselves
mark a nihilistic gloss of world this
loss and its expression require our
thoughtful even compassionate exposure
in order to move students toward
curiosity about and reinvestment in
larger order trajectories of power and
values yet study scrutiny and deepening
of value concerns is not how
undergraduate curriculums are designed
today apart from pressure from every
quarter to turn all but elite colleges
and vocational directions putatively
norm free methods in mainstream social
science where values remain unwelcome
and illegal aliens actively discourage
scholarly discussion of exactly this
kind in most social
science classes this is compounded in
the study of social and political
behavior and certain kinds of philosophy
by the reduction of values to norms
norms to opinions and opinions to
personal beliefs or attitudes for Weber
value simultaneously bear our individual
human depth and are at the heart of
collective self making they are for him
uniquely threatened by the forces of
modernity diminishing our capacity and
our belief in our capacity to craft our
lives and the conditions of our lives
this for him is the essence of nihilism
culturing value and placing struggle
over it at the heart of renewing
democracy is all that carries the
alternative to rule by unchosen forms of
rationality and apparatuses of
domination by pure power mongers or by
technocrats indeed weber x' insistence
on warring god heads as the essence of
political life is itself an anti
nihilist counter to Schmidt's infamous
identification of that struggle with the
friend enemy distinction to Lennon's
reduction of politics to who whom who
will dominate or overtake home order the
classic realist position that politics
is governed by objective laws with their
roots in human nature
it was vapers appreciation of the
inherently political and creative nature
of value and politics as the platform
for struggling over value that led him
to reject the neo-kantian effort to
ground values and moral universals the
neo-marxist effort to embed values in
materialism and teleology the neo-nazi
an effort to invest culture or great
individuals with the redemption of
values and what would become the
neoliberal surrender of values to
markets and moral traditionalism yet
even as he rejected rationalist
naturalist theological or other
millenarian foundations weber sought to
make values
mountable to thought and tether their
enactment to responsibility
we've spent these evenings with Faber
because for all of his evident
limitations in looming the kinds of
social and political theory that we
might need to apprehend our current
conjuncture or renew possibility within
it Weber did understand that rekindling
the value of value amidst its nihilistic
diminution or destruction entails
recommitting to our humaneness in a
double sense values carry our
distinctive political capacity to craft
the world according to chosen purposes
when that capacity seems nearly
extinguished by the forces now governing
and imperiling our lives and future this
recommitment also entails embrace of the
purely human construction of values and
of our complexly human thinking feeling
psychic cultural and historical
attachment to them far from nihilism as
some have suggested this embrace bears
the promise of nihilism
overcoming only by affirming that we
invent the values by which we live and
that our yearnings and fears attachments
and repulsions and not only our
traditions and intellects are all at
play in this invention have we a chance
at becoming responsible for the enormous
powers that our species alone is capable
of unleashing including on ourselves
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think we get to talk to this time
right
we talked briefly last night and I told
her I was very nervous to talk to her
but now I feel like now you're doing it
in public weird one-on-one but in public
I'm totally fine um so yesterday I think
more than today you talked about how we
need to hold ourselves accountable as a
society and teach ourselves to desire a
society in which we are fair and we see
our lifestyle is sustainable and holding
ourselves accountable and each other
accountable and it sounds like that
would make everyone so self-conscious
and anxious that we wouldn't be able to
have meaningful interactions with people
and take risks and that sounds like even
more audience oriented subjectivity than
however most talked about in his time it
seems like it's very justified which you
talked about we are young people like I
just graduated from college I'm
terrified
how do you think that you talked about
on a curriculum level how professors
should teach us to temper our anxiety
and over responsibility and being really
anxious about worrying about offending
other people how do you think that an
individual in our inner voice could
temper Anne's aya t / responsibility and
deliberation or do you think that at
this point anxiety is inevitable in
trying to be intellectually sound like
what's something that a 24 year old like
myself could tell myself every day to
evade anxiety / am I gonna say the wrong
thing to the wrong person today I feel
like everything is being recorded
everybody has a camera on their phone
it's very audience oriented subjectivity
constantly
so to the question of whether anxiety is
inevitable today I think the simple
answer is yes
for lots and lots of reasons but the
particular kind of anxiety that I think
you're describing was not when I was
addressing but it is an important kind
and I think that what you're describing
is anxiety about articulating views
positions desires wishes hopes
preferences in a world in which you have
become inordinately self-conscious about
a Anan shared worldview and be your own
historicity and cultural place visa vie
others with different histories
different cultural places it's
unfortunate that that has become our
preoccupation because I think it's
actually quite damaging to the
possibility of just being able to be at
home in your thinking and so forth but
damaging to the possibility of being
able to think together about what's
really empowering us in this world so
when I said briefly that I think the
preoccupation with one's own personal
political positioning whether it's about
being offended or potentially offending
others is itself a bit of a nihilistic
expression here's what I meant that I
think it's a symptom of a certain
withdrawal from world abandonment of
world and what I referred to yesterday
as that crisis of desire or collapse of
desire for world and for making a world
it's a defensive crouching posture or
it's a reactive vengeful posture but it
has its it's actually choked in its
powers and choked in its sense that
there's the possibility of building a
world two with one another so I don't
have a
Media therapeutic solution fruit and
your anxiety other than to try to create
conditions whether in classrooms or in
public spaces or in political work in
which that is not our main preoccupation
in which instead we try to ask ourselves
the question again and again what kind
of world do we want to live in what kind
of world are we trying to build what are
the powers that currently impaired oh
that possibility and what are the
possibilities of contesting those powers
with alternatives and those questions
attempt to leap over or diminish the
power of that anxious preoccupation with
self what I called yesterday the
reduction to a world of one in a world
of now that is itself part of the
nihilistic predicament on the other hand
I think there's other kinds of anxiety
that are absolutely inevitable and
ubiquitous today that simply have to do
with existential disaster but also the
illiberal ism breeds a very particular
kind of anxiety that tending of human
capital that I talked about is a 24/7
project and it's one you know that only
those who sleep will lose and I'm not
suggesting that therefore you don't
sleep I'm suggesting that you think
about whether tend in your human capital
is really what you want to do in this
world and how you want to make a
difference in this world now everyone
can opt out of it at every moment you
know an uber driver can't be snarly and
continue to drive that capital has to be
tended I don't tell my graduate students
to just say what they think at every
moment on the other hand I do think
considering what you really want to work
on what you really want to do and what
kind of world do you want to bring into
being is all that's left because
otherwise we will die clutching our
human capital and there's better things
to Klutch when you die
thank you so much yep when the Mart
thanks so much
two quick questions one for labor and
one for you
okay certain for Weber on knowledge with
all of the distinctions that you
enumerated and that are familiar to many
of us most of us probably what happens
to hermeneutics what happens to need for
interpretation it seems to me that
that's kind of built into this and shaft
but but violates all the binaries that
he yes that's that's for Weber for you
we use please say more about democracy
oh okay
it's trying to get away from myself in
these talks um Morris of course you're
right any any a Weber a student of Weber
knows that he often gets misrepresented
as a positivist who was anything but he
believed deeply in hermeneutics he
fought for hermeneutics against the
positivist in his time and thought that
what you had to do in order to interpret
facts did not change the fact of their
being facts and what you do is not
bringing values to facts but you bring
the problem of interpreting them to
facts so it's a kind of hermeneutics
that we have made messes of over the
20th century patch a got a mur and many
others but his understanding of the
hermeneutic project was about the
interpretation of facts and the
interpretation of values but wasn't one
that challenged the facticity of the
object there's more to say on that but
I'll leave it alone what did you want me
to what aspect of democracy did you want
me to talk about
yeah okay so sorry might I add cuz my
question yes please great great
wonderful pair of talks because bereft
in Peru
I guess my question would be though at
the end you had a negative attitude
toward vocational education which
stressing strange given that both of
papers essays were about vocations
and so my question on the democracy is
it seems as if you sent me back to read
those essays that the education of
politics for a vocation and of knowledge
for a vocation was not imagined as
education for all Democratic citizens
that's right but actually for people who
were going to be either scholars or
politicians that's right and that's
where the question of what a democratic
to education would follow that would be
different from either vapers vocational
education or the education that you
spoke to whether just to think of two of
his contemporaries either Dewey's census
of a democratic education or Gramsci's
sense that everyone is a legislator
everyone is an intellectual great so um
trying to think about where to go with
this one of the reasons that I find
vapers essays so provocative and love to
teach them is precisely that he speaks
to the contemporary set of problems and
a contemporary set of forces our
contemporary forces and problems from
what seems like a deeply conservative
and even anti-democratic direction
you're absolutely right that his
understanding of what scholarship is for
is not for an educated democracy and
teaching is not even to educate students
although they're those gestures those I
mean educate Democratic citizens there
are those gestures when he said
you know clarifying values clarifying
the meaning of your values and their
he's really talking to scolding the
Bolsheviks and the Socialists in his
classrooms you know understanding what
you really stand for and what the
implications are of what you really
stand for and the violence of what you
may stand for is part of what we do as
responsible educators so they're those
gestural moments that go toward being a
thinking citizen but for the most part
that accumulative dimension of knowledge
is is for scholars themselves or for
science itself and potentially for the
development of technique in the world
but it's not actually about educating
the masses and that's why I said he
leaves it kind of leaves us to our
cultural psychic stew that he knows
nihilism has produced and therefore
joins in those who would go for a pleb
asset or a democracy or fairly contained
stripped-down democracy one of the
reasons they so interesting to me is
that he's the precursor to the
neoliberal anti-democratic force that
the order liberals Hayek and others will
develop the the suspicion that democracy
if it ever was useful for anything is
over in the age of mass and franchise
meant so then the question is what what
do we do with him there what do we what
do we what why why did I take that make
that move against vocational training or
converting universities into vocational
training and make the argument for what
we classically call liberal arts
education it's probably not so common in
the experience at Yale and its
associates as it is in the public
universities this enormous press to make
students job ready the moment that they
graduate and by job ready really what's
meant is their readiness to enter not
simply the the higher professions
but jobs in which they have technical
skills so that they don't have to go to
coding school after they have their BA
so that they don't have to add to their
education but can go right into
mid-level professional jobs and what of
course is being pressed out there as the
idea of educating Democratic citizens
and I've written a lot about this and so
of a lot of other people but I mean
obviously they couldn't come at a worse
time in history the need for not just
literacy visa vie media and being able
to separate fact from garbage on the
internet but the importance of actually
being deeply educated in a range of
fields has probably never been more
important if we're going to have a
democracy it's the time in history when
it is no longer possible to imagine
democracy working if what if citizens
themselves don't have basic
understandings about or basic basic
literacies in economics politics history
and social life and I don't mean
sophisticated versions of that I mean
just knowing how to think about what
they're hearing and encountering in the
world and having some sense of where we
are in time and space in the early part
of this century and I think therefore
that the press for vocational training
in its opposite meaning not the meaning
that Weber meant I didn't spend time on
this and this si have written about it
elsewhere but the idea of the calling
the being drawn to something but also
being in service to a particular
activity or project or purpose in the
world that Weber secularize --is from
its divine form is absolutely the
opposite to that job readiness that
availability to and ready
for training so I have been arguing for
years that nothing is more important to
renewing democracy than educating for
democracy and nothing has been more
powerful in destroying democracy than
dis educating than wiping out not just
the meaning of the value of of higher
education but also in trying to alter
what it would be for I will also add
that I don't think we on the Left have
helped that situation I think we have
tried to argue for the importance of the
humanities or the importance of our
various kinds of obscure practices and
research as as if that's at the heart of
educating for democracy and I personally
actually believe that whatever we are
called to research is one thing what we
need to be doing in educating for
democracy is another I have never
completely bought the line that that the
scholar teacher is a unified subject and
I'm at odds with most of my colleagues
in that respect I think we really need
to think hard about what kinds of
curriculums what kinds of courses what
kinds of books what kinds of texts and
what kinds of conversations Democratic
citizens need to have today and they
will not be just you know left or right
or anything else it's more about you
know what do they need to be steeped in
and that's really different than what I
love thinking about in my study and I'm
perfectly happy to live with that split
I don't know that all of my colleagues
are
okay there is another event coming in
this one I promise them
great thank you for your question
[Music]